THROUGHOUT OUR COUNTY.
LAWRENCE: UNBELIEVABLE.
TONIGHT I'M JOINED BY A PANEL OF
BREVARD COUNTY SCHOOL STAFF
MEMBERS.
GENE TRENGT AND EARNEST THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING ME.
>> ALICIA I WANT TO GO TO YOU
FIRST YOU'VE BEEN DLOANG FOR 19
YEARS.
WHAT IS THE STATE OF THESE
CLASSROOMS?
IT'S SCARY IT'S NOT LIKE IT USED
TO BE AND KIDS KNOW THERE'S NOT
ANY CONSEQUENCES SO THEY'RE NOT
AFRAID, AND IT'S JUST --
IT'S FOR ME PERSONALLY IT IS
SCARY EVERY DAY BEGINNING TO
WORK.
>> I WANT TO FOLLOW-UP WITH YOU
WHEN YOU SAY SCARY --
WHAT IS THE CLASSROOM LIKE?
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING WHAT IS
BEING DONE TO YOU?
>> WE HAVE ABOUT 20 KIDS AND TWO
EXTREME BEHAVIORS IN THE
CLASSROOM, AND THOSE TAKE MOST
OF OUR ATTENTION.
I AM DEFLECTING BEING ATTACKED,
SCRATCHED --
SHE'S STUDENTS HAVE GONE FOR MY
THROAT.
PULLED MY HAIR --
THROWN ME AGAINST THE WALL.
AND IT'S EVERYDAY OCCURRENCE
RIGHT NOW.
LAWRENCE: THIS IS ASSAULT.
ERNEST YOU SAY THAT YOU NEED
MORE CONTROL IN THE CLASSROOM.
SO WHO'S PREVENTING THAT FROM
HAPPENING?
>> YES.
WELL --
I THINK MYSELF, I THINK IT'S THE
LAWS THAT OWN THE BOOKS.
THAT WHAT A TEACHER CAN DO AND
WHAT A TEACHER CANNOT DO A
TEACHER NEED MORE CONTROL OVER
THEIR CLASSROOM.
OKAY --
SAY FOR INSTANCE WHEN YOU GET A
CHILD THAT WALK OUT THE CLASS A
WITHOUT PERMISSION.
DON'T ALLOW THEM BACK IN THE
CLASSROOM.
>> ERNEST, WHERE ARE THE
PARENTS?
I MEAN, THIS IS A DIRECT
REFLECTION OF WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN THE HOUSEHOLD.
I WAS MORE AFRAID OF GOING HOME
IF I WOULD DO SOMETHING LIKE
THIS.
OF WHAT MY PARENTS WOULD DO TO
ME IF I DID THIS TO A TEACHER.
>> WELL, SEE THAT GO RIGHT BACK
TO THE STATE AGAIN.
BECAUSE WHAT THE STATE DO, THE
STATE TELL THE PARENTS THEY
KIDS, THE KIDS COME TO SCHOOL
UNDISCIPLINED, UNSUPERVISED AND
THEY EXPECT THEM TO TEACH --
TEACHER TO TEACH THEIR KID AND
TO RAISE THEIR KID.
THE SCHOOL IS NOT --
THE SCHOOL IS NOT A BABY-SITTER.
THEY ARE NOT THERE TO BABY-SIT
YOUR KID.
THEY ARE THERE TO TRAIN AND
TEACH YOUR KID.
OKAY, AND THIS IS WHERE THE
STATE NEED TO STEP IN AND CHANGE
SOME LAW WHEN THESE KIDS ACT UP
THE WAY THEY DO IN CLASS YOU
SENDING THEM BACK HOME TO
PARENTS AND GIVE PARENTS ENOUGH
TEAM TO COME SEE TO GET THEIR
CHILD.
IF THEY DON'T COME THAT'S WHEN
YOU SENT SHERIFF DEPUTY AND
CONDUCT COME IN AND YOU HAVE TO
CHANGE IT WHEREAS THESE PARENTS
HELD MORE RESPONSIBLE.
LAWRENCE: WE'RE GOING TALK TO
THE SHERIFF IN JUST A MOMENT AND
POST SOME OF THOSE QUESTIONS TO
HIM AS WELL.
BUT GENE I HAVE TO GET USE IN.
YOU'RE ON THE BOARD.
WHAT IS THE BOARD SAYING ABOUT
THIS?
BECAUSE YOU GUYS VERY ELECTED TO
NOT ONLY REPRESENT PEOPLE, THE
STUDENTS BUT THESE TEACHERS AS
WELL.
>> YES, WE ARE LAWRENCE, AND I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU KNOW BUT THIS
IS A NEW BOARD.
WE FLIPPED THE BOARD IN
NOVEMBER, AND I TRULY BELIEVE
THAT'S WHY WE'RE NOW HEARING
ABOUT ALL OF THE HORROR STORIES
THAT ARE IN, WITHIN OUR
CLASSROOM PPS I DON'T BELIEVE
BREVARD IS ANY DIFFERENT THAN
ANY COUNTY IN OUR STATE OR
COUNTRY.
I BELIEVE THIS IS REALLY LIKE
THE ME TOO MOVEMENT OF
EDUCATION.
NOW, TEACHERS ARE COMFORTABLE
COMING OUT AND TALKING BECAUSE
OF THE MAKEUP OF OUR BOARD SO WE
NEED TO PROVIDE THE SAFEST
ENVIRONMENT FOR OUR CHILDREN TO
LEARN, AND WE'RE GOING TO DO
EVERYTHING LEGALLY THAT WE CAN
DO AND THAT'S WHAT WE'VE STARTED
HERE IN BREVARD COUNTY.
WHAT YOU PLAN TO DO I WANT TO
READ THIS STATEMENT FROM THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT HOPING THAT YOU
CAN SHED SOME LIGHT ON IT.
THIS IS WHAT THEY SAID BEHAVIOR
AND DISCIPLINE IS IMPORTANT TO
OUR SCHOOL BOARD AND THAT IS WHY
THEY HAVE BEGUN FOCUSING EVEN
MORE TIME AND ENERGY ON THE
TOPIC.
IT IS A CONFLICT ISSUE THAT
DESERVING INPUT FROM OUR ENTIRE
COMMUNITY AN IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT BEHAVIOR INVOLVES MORE THAN
JUST THE ACTIONS AND ATTITUDES
OF STUDENTS.
IT ALSO INVOLVES THE ACTIONS AND
ATTITUDES OF STAFF, AND
FAMILIES.
OUR GOAL AS A SCHOOL DISTRICT
WILL ALWAYS BE TO PROVIDE THE
BEST LEARNING ENVIRONMENT
POSSIBLE AND WE CALL ON EVERYONE
IN OUR COMMUNITY TO HELP MAKE
THAT HAPPEN.
WE CAN DO THAT IF EACH PERSON
VOWS TO TREAT EACH STUDENT EACH
EMPLOYEES, AND THESE FAMILY WITH
RESPECT AND DECENCY.
WILDING THEMSELVES ACCOUNTABLE
FOR THEIR OWN ACTIONS.
AND I'M SORRY, SIR, IT LOOKS
LIKE THEY'RE VICTIM BLAMING.
BECAUSE I DON'T SEE A LOT OF
IMAGES OF THE STUDENTS BEING
BITTEN.
I DON'T SEE IMAGE BEING RELEASED
OF BRUISING ON THE STUDENTS.
I SEE IT ON THE TEACHERS.
BUT THEY WANT TO EQUALLY --
PLACE THE BLAME ON THE TEACHERS
AS WELL.
WHY IS THAT?
>> WELL THAT'S UNFORTUNATE
LAWRENCE, AND WE WOANGTS PUT UP
WITH THAT.
THIS IS NOT STUDENTS ON STUDENTS
MISBEHAVIOR OR VIOLENCE THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE.
THIS IS BUS DRIVERS GETTING HIT
IN THE BACK OF THE HEAD WITH A
WATER BOTTLE THIS IS TEACHERS
BEING BITTEN, CHOKED, WE WILL
NOT ALLOW THIS TO HAPPEN.
THIS IS NOT, THEN --
SOMETHING THAT JUST COME UP
OVERNIGHT.
WE HAVE FOUND OUT THAT OUR
TEACHERS UNION HAS BEEN ASKING
OUR DISTRICT TO HANDLE OR TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES NOT THIS
YEAR NOT LAST YEAR, BUT MANY
YEARS AND IT JUST HAS NOT WORK
OUT THAT WAY TRUST ME WHEN I SAY
I'M NOT ALWAYS THE FAN OF THE
TEACHERS UNION.
BUT IN THIS CASE, WE'RE ALL
AWARE OF WHAT'S GOING ON AND WE
IN THIS NEW SCHOOL BOARD WE'RE
JUST NOT GOING TO ALLOW THIS TO
CONTINUE.
>> WHAT DOW TO SEE HAPPEN RIGHT
NOW?
>> WELL, IN EXTREME SITUATIONS I
FEEL LIKE THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME
SORT OF OF EMERGENCY PLAN THERE
ARE FEDERAL LAWS THAT PROTECT
OUR CHILDREN AND THEY NEED TO
PROTECT YOU FEEL OUR CHILDREN
AND ALL OF OUR STAFF SO THAT
THERE'S A SAFE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT FOR OUR KIDS.
AND THE KIDS SHOULD FEEL SAFE
AND SECURE AT SCHOOL.
STAFF SHOULD FEEL SAFE AND
SECURE AT SCHOOL.
SO IF IT'S A MATTER OF, YOU
KNOW, WE HAVE TO GO BY FEDERAL
GUIDELINES BUT THERE'S GOT TO BE
HELP AND EXTREME CIRCUMSTANCES
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
>> ALICIA WE HAVE THE PHOTOS OF
THE ABUSE THAT YOU'VE ENDURED I
DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW YOU'RE
TEACHING BUT THANK YOU ALL FOR
WHAT YOU D